ya se dio salida a esta edición número
108 del tour de francia desde aquí
bretaña región al noroeste del país una
etapa de 197 kilómetros entre basto y
londres que tendrá una llegada muy
emocionante una subida de 13 kilómetros
hasta la fosa de los lobos un terreno
ideal para los puntos como por ejemplo
el francés william la philippe el actual
campeona mundial de ruta pero también
macho bandas por un botón
por supuesto se espera que los favoritos
no pierdan tiempo en esta primera etapa
estamos hablando por una parte del
defensor del título está de yo ponga
chat y también de su compatriota el
esloveno primoz orobitg quien este año
vuelve a buscar el título que perdió por
poquito del año pasado junto a yumbo
visma las esperanzas latinoamericanas
están por una parte en el ecuatoriano
richard cara paz que en este año pues
regresa con el equipo y negocios que no
contará con la presencia de gana bernal
en este tour y también nairo quintana
con ar que assange y quien este año no
espera ser campeón de este tour pero si
aspira a ser el campeón
de la montaña y por último también se
espera una gran participación de
miguelángel superman lópez el colombiano
que con el equipo movistar pues aspira a
llevarse algo más que una victoria de
etapa como lo hizo en 2020